le public criait pour que nous
rentrions à la maison et cette histoire a
bien joué et nous a
permis de donner au public avec elle
voulait rentrer à la maison Je ne suis pas
étranger aux grandes foules tout le monde
applaudit en passant un bon moment Je suis  pas
étranger aux gens impressionnés par ma
beauté et clairement mon humilité euh c'est
génial c'est tellement amusant viens ici
tout le monde passe un bon moment c'est une
fête et vous savez que c'est une
fête pour la fête du film
pour la fête des fans et la vie de
Paul, donc nous célébrons tous
celui-ci prend un peu le gâteau, vous
savez, les fans sont un peu enthousiastes
pour dire le moins, c'est génial
incroyable juste des blocs et des blocs de vous
savez et comme c'est bizarre parce que c'est
comme si c'était tellement public et pourtant c'est  se sent
très personnel quand vous avez réellement des
contacts avec les fans et vous savez que c'est
incroyable d'être mieux en ce moment c'est un
peu doux-amer parce que nous avons un garçon
qui doit être rempli mais je pense qu'il est
à l'étage un  d il nous regarde de haut et
sourit en ce moment parce que nous l'honorons à 100%
dans ce film et c'est fait
de la meilleure façon possible ici
ne se compare à aucun sentiment que j'ai jamais
eu dans ma
vie attendu longtemps  temps et il y a tellement
de raisons évidemment pour lesquelles nous voulons
voir ce film et c'est juste pour l'
excitation est vraiment trop vraiment oh mon
Dieu fou j'ai du mal à comprendre
toute cette
folie mais c'est tellement excité et je suis
très reconnaissant de faire partie de la famille